how many Final Fantasy games have you
played uh I have finished zero Final
Fantasy games
I've played a lot I've played a lot how
many of you played and not finished uh
seven eight
nine that's gotta be a crime that isn't
it I'm crying uh hearing this yes I I
think I got I think yeah ten uh I've
started ff7 remake haven't finished that
the biggest the biggest thing that gets
me to stop playing bro bro read like 1
000 chapters in one piece and thought
I'm done
I mean the biggest thing that has
stopped me from finishing it is
turn-based combat and uh because I just
get bored I I get bored doing turn-based
combat uh and you know especially in the
older games you have to spend a lot of
hours grinding out the turn-based combat
and then I just go I just get to a point
where I get bored and I'm like okay I'm
just gonna take a break from the game
take a break and then never come back uh
and with 16 because I really [__]
like the gameplay I I will probably like
stick through it it's probably giving my
people a first Final Fantasy game I
finished
I mean yeah I think that's just how we
consume games differently I like to
binge I like to just destroy a game in
one go and be like I'm done yeah and I
feel satisfied that way because before I
even get a chance to be like I'm bored
of this I'm done
um yeah I can only play like
it's eight hours maximum in a day before
my mind turns into like mush and I just
like I need to like step away
like 14 hours in right but then I can
keep going and keep going but it doesn't
feel good for me it depends on the game
like I could there could be some games
where I'm like this is just like a
couple of hours type of thing and then I
gotta wait I gotta you know save it for
tomorrow and then this game's like 13
Sentinels where it's like if I spend any
time away from this game I'm going to
forget everything about this level
because it's so [__] confusing I
finished that game in three days I need
a 30-hour game and I bet you remember
nothing about it
no I remember a decent amount of it only
because like for those three days I just
only because for those three days it's
all I was [__] thinking about yeah
and it's a [__] fantastic story it's
great it's great yeah there's there's
just a lot I I needed a day to process
some of the like plot twists in that
game are you the type of [__] in
13 Sentinels that went to like the
encyclopedia section of course
that is literally like the the when you
describe doing that to me I'm like
that's like just being like you know I
just enjoy castration it's just fun okay
I can't imagine anything more [__]
unfun in my life than opening up an
encycloped I have to read
because it there's okay I like I'm not
[__] Okay I'm the [__]
if there is a like let's say a TV series
that I really really [__] enjoy I'm
that [__] who's like I will
watch like an hour YouTube video
breaking down the lore of [__] that
happened before the story tape like took
place you know I I love if if I'm like
emotionally invested in something I want
to know as much of the world as possible
because it just helps immerse me in the
story that's being told see I feel
though that only becomes gratifying when
you make it to the end what do you mean
yeah you've got to finish the goddamn
you've got to finish the if you're
you're so focused on finding out like
what happened to these characters in
this world in the setting before the
game took place but you'd never see it
to the end no no it's like like you
don't care about how a result percentage
of the like in these games did you drop
out between like 10 in 50 in what do you
mean like with the Final Fantasy game
how far in were you before
uh about 50 I think [__] it up that's
crazy that's crazy to be fair to be fair
I didn't so far drop it I just never
finished
for me for my my rule of thumb is if I'm
not invested in the game by around 20 30
of the way through I don't see it to the
end I feel 20 30 is like a kind of a
good time to get a good indication of
like is this game even worth finishing I
don't know I mean for me it's like hours
it's like if I if I'm not if I'm not
hooked an hour and 30 minutes in I'm
done right and an hour and 30 minutes
yeah 10 of the tutorial and like Jr no I
know which is why I always struggle
because it's like I just don't know if
this is worth investing and I'm not
interested in spending 10 hours figuring
out if I should be invested no for me
this takes me like minimum 10 hours for
jail people to be like am I invested
enough in the story yeah that's what
sucked though because when I played
eight I I wouldn't have there's no shot
I would have stuck with it if I if I
spent an hour playing it because I was
like yeah this game is I don't know
anything this game ever I think every
Final Fantasy does this they just throw
a bunch of menuing at you they're like
oh this is this this is this you're like
this is a ridiculous amount of
information to ask someone to take in uh
and and just through like explanations
and it's like yeah none of this makes
[__] sense you and it's like you guys
are insane for thinking that someone
would sit 10 hours through this to do it
and people do obviously but I'm like
it's [__] that they design a game that
is just not fun for 10 hours and then
then you're like okay but now it's one
is subjective yeah one is subjective I
find it fun learning new mechanics I
mean yeah I found it fun when I got the
hang of it but it's crazy I mentioned
this when we played initially but like
it's crazy that I felt like I got the
hang of it like 20 hours in that's
insane did you enjoy the story of eight
yeah yeah I did yeah yeah I liked it a
lot yeah I thought it was fun okay I
thought it was okay what's what's the
general consensus of the story of seven
is it like the it's actually the best
one it's great it's great yeah I don't
think it's the best Final Fantasy in my
opinion but I think it's a very very
song I thought sephiroth was like the
villain in all of them
I realized he was only in seven because
but then for some reason he was just the
poster boy for Final Fantasy villains
yes because so a lot of people seven was
their first Final Fantasy because it was
the first 3D Final Fantasy yeah I've I
was I'm having like [__] it's been
ingrained in my head and I can't stop
thinking about it and I've been thinking
about it the entire conversation we're
talking about it so this Tick Tock of
someone would like zephyruff hair like
dancing and it's like yeah when he like
kills your entire family it's him like
twerking and like flailing his hair
around like I can't stop thinking about
this that's why that's why I'm so glad
seven got the Remake because like it is
in my in my opinion the original Seven
is like close to unplayable because it's
just because it's got a great [__]
story and the combat system is great but
I just can't get over the graphics now I
I actually I'm having huge [__] a
huge [__] trouble playing through the
Remake really yeah but I think the
remakes because like I remember playing
Final Fantasy seven yeah when I was a
kid I don't remember [__] I remember all
I know about it is that there's like
they go to like a strip club or
something that's all I know
yeah that's all I know about it yeah but
like I think I'm like noticing about him
because like I don't know I'm I'm
playing I'm playing the Remake I'm about
like 10 12 hours is it right like it's
gonna be three games as well that's
[__] when when do you start liking the
characters
I'm just gonna be straight up I am just
gonna be straight when you start liking
the characters well I feel for a lot of
people there's a Nostalgia Factor
playing the remix right like at least
for me I had it like you know when I saw
like [__] you know you know when [__]
uh you know when you first see cloud and
everything you're like is that
[__] there's that [__]
I've already spent hundreds of hours so
far clouds to me like has got as much
characterization as your general isakai
protagonist
I'm like when does cloud become
interesting Strife copied from Kirito
like this wow the absolute audacity
Square Enix
that so far has just been the childhood
friend hey don't bad mouth TV she's my
[__] wife
I'm just like I don't think yuffie's
been introduced yet but like the the
only mind wait until
[__] I like so far as Barrett
and I'm just like yeah but Everyone
likes okay because it seems like he has
a personality he's like jet he's from
cowboy it's like you just automatically
love him he is I don't and I'm just like
because I remember going into this being
like this is the classic everyone loves
this Final Fantasy yeah this is going to
be a banger I love jrpgs and I'm just
like when do when do the characters get
interesting I'm uh I'm I'm I'm I'm
waiting I'm 10 hours in normally I'm
normally I'm hooked now on the jrpg just
wait till yuffie comes out and you'll be
hooked I don't want something about
sephiroth twerking you I'm listening to
you talking it's all I can talk about I
don't know why she's here she's like I
know it's like a super serious story as
well I'm just imagining him twerking
yeah but several doesn't come out until
like way way way later okay generally
though what what draws you to like cloud
and Tifa
um
I think
played all the other final fantasies and
I've played a lot of jrpgs that were
just like yeah
unlikable why didn't you come to jrpg
man I already am
because
yeah
and yeah and then I'll get to the point
where I'm just stop playing guys yeah
I'm only playing Call of Duty yeah I'm
only playing first person shooters
I think it's because like look it's in
my opinion like you know like uh cloud
and Tifa and like that whole gang is
like they're I think there are solid
cast of characters I'm not gonna say
they're the best Castle character who is
the best cast of characters in Final
Fantasy game in a Final Fantasy game
RPGs I think I because I I come into
this I come into Final Fantasy 7 after
playing so many of my favorite jrpgs
yeah and with the critical claim that I
had I was expecting more I guess yeah
from the characters okay
one game that I've always wanted to play
and I'll say this because I'm just gonna
forget if I don't say it right now yeah
uh one job G that I've always been
interested in and everyone always talks
about is like one of the best ever is
like Chrono Trigger yes always one of
the playbacks it looks fun okay you you
asked me what the best cast of
characters in jrpg is I probably say
chronography like Chrono Trigger did
something like not only like like what
was amazing about that game like for one
one of the best game soundtracks ever
made in my opinion uh two it's just like
a really interesting concept of not only
combat Concepts back in the day because
like back when Chrono Trigger came out
that it's not turn based anymore it's
like it's not your like average Final
Fantasy turn base it's like turn based
with a mix of real time yeah yeah right
and that was like unheard of when that
came out so that was already amazing and
then just this [__] story is I've
heard the stories which if I really want
to play it yeah it's an incredible game
you should definitely play it yeah like
playing through Final Fantasy 16 now
makes me want to play again now yeah is
there a second one there is on like PS1
right or something uh there's chronic
Crusade oh yeah that's something which
is something different yeah like playing
blue through Final Fantasy 60 now
because I looked up the completion time
of Final Fantasy 16 and it's like you
know some people completed in like 35
hours which is English
which to me is like seems like
incredibly short foreign
completion time of a Final Fantasy game
no it's more like 50 60 angles usually
most of them were like because I've been
because I've actually been looking which
one to play next most of them have been
clocking in at like 35. really yeah I
mean I mean name one I'll just have a
look right now all right all right time
because I remember maybe I was just like
a dumbass kid trying to figure this [__]
out but like I remember the first time
I'd be Final Fantasy 6 35 hours
dude I spent like uh serious yeah ten
okay wow 46 hours yeah 10 is long she's
okay what about uh what does it feel a
lot longer nine is 39
it feels way longer wait look up 13
Sentinels how long does that take it
took me like actually that took me 30
hours I literally use this website for
everything because I'm like when I'm
streaming I gotta know how long because
I I am the average gamer if not better
than the average gamer at most games
that's like what I would love to clock
in at and then streaming kind of slows
it down so I'm normally around what
about Chrono tree
I think I beat it in like 50 60 hours
uh when focusing on the main objectives
23 hours but it's if you were trying to
do 100 42 hours can you can you search
up I might just I might have just
accidentally done 100 can you search up
Persona 5 yes because that is a long
time that's a long game that is
what a hundred hours
173 hours to 100 checks out yes I think
I think these are like what what this I
think how this website works is that
people play the game and it's like a
community thing so shout out to submit
it shout out to the people who submit I
think you're doing it you are you are
helping so much
um yeah so I think that's on average
yeah that means that if you're a fast
gamer could be 90 but if a lot of people
it could be like 100 oh first time was
Persona 5 for me and I definitely took
more than 100 yeah I took more than 100.
those are interesting seeing how uh on
the different platforms or changes
sometimes people who played on like PC
can emulate so they can speed it up okay
what's the longest Final Fantasy game
what is the longest I feel like it's 10
yeah or maybe one of the 13 games
uh
yeah yeah I can see that that was pretty
long yeah
20 sounds great this looks like like 20
hours to complete a main story for jrpg
that sounds so nice and digestible it
needs to get into it if it's like a good
game like I said I want to be immersed
in much possible you ask me why I've
read law and why I read Wiki articles is
because like I to me like good World
building the world should exist even if
the story isn't being imagining like God
reading the law while saffron's twerking
ending the world
yeah that's uh that's actually uh that's
a Canon event actually
yeah like like to me like a good World
should exist even if the main story
being told didn't exist the world should
still function and to me just like the
world existing to me is almost even
sometimes more interesting than the
story being told by whatever whatever it
is you know that's how aliens feel when
they saw like World War II going on they
were like I just want to know what the
world's doing
but I have no interest in getting
involved oh the background law is behind
World War II I was an alien like
so that's pretty interesting actually
yeah alien's watching has been like you
know they uh they were arguing about
toilet paper before this yeah
fascinating stuff truly